[Music]  to the best of my understandably shaky  recollection  the first time i died went something  like this  that's a pretty cool first line actually  if i do give myself some credit  what i'm going to try to do with the  class is go right from the beginning  from  ideas for books really terrific sports  writer named red smith said  writing is easy all you do is stare at a  blank piece of paper  until drops of blood form on your  forehead  we'll deal with outlines outlines are  huge how to create a scene  be careful of oh i get it figured out i  don't want to read anymore  that's death every short story i ever  sent  out was rejected my first novel was  turned down by 31 publishers  it's rare that somebody comes up with a  totally fresh idea out of nowhere  you already know how to do it write the  story don't  write sentences why am i doing this  because i've been there it's a daunting  thing to sit down and start a book  i'm james patterson this is my master  class  you